Speaker 1: Stephen Bannon, former Trump
propagandist Stephen Bannon awaiting
sentencing. He is now potentially facing six
months in jail and a $200,000 fine. CNBC reports
the Department of Justice wants Steve Bannon
jailed for six months for contempt of Congress,
but Ex-Trump aide is asking for probation. This is
typical. Prosecution usually asks for a stricter
punishment than the person who is about to be
sentenced. The key points, as reported by CNBC,
federal prosecutors recommended Steve Bannon get
six months in jail for defying that subpoena from
the congressional probe of the January six Capitol
riot. Remember, what is at issue here is that the
January six committee subpoenaed Steve Bannon and
he ignored it. That's called contempt of Congress,
and indeed, that is what he will be ultimately
sentenced for. The DOJ also sought a $200,000
fine for Bannon, who was a senior adviser and
former President Donald Trump's White House,
the DOJ. J recommended the maximum fine and
top sentence under the federal guidelines
range because of Bannon's consistent, quote,
bad faith strategy of defiance and contempt.
Bannon's lawyers are asking the federal
court for a sentence of probation. Now,
there are some who are reacting to this and have
emailed me and said, David, you know, I don't like
Steve Bannon as much as the next person, but this
is just too high. I mean, six months for defying
a subpoena. That's bonkers. On the other hand,
there are people who wrote in and said, you know,
this is actually really serious. If we actually
are for law and order and we respect separation
of powers and we respect the constitutionally
assigned task of the House of Representatives
Representatives to conduct investigations,
then you have to take really seriously what
Steve Bannon did, because he deliberately,
willingly, brazenly, I would argue, obstructed
the House of Representatives from carrying out
its constitutionally assigned task. And that
needs to be taken really seriously. You can make
arguments on both sides. I do believe that this
needs to be taken seriously. And I know that the
stricter the penalty for Stephen Bannon, the more
he and other Trumpists will make him out to be a
martyr, someone who was made an example out of for
no reason other than the MAGA people are being
attacked and whatever else. But you've still
got to assign the penalties that are appropriate
for the wrongdoing that was done and it should be
taken seriously. So we have the sentencing coming
up. Let me see if I can find the actual date here
in the article. He's going to be sentenced Friday.
Okay. So by the beginning of next week, we will
know about that. However, his lawyers also asked
to stay in his sentence, imposed pending the
outcome of an appeal. So once the sentence
happens, it's not likely that if prison is
or jail, rather is assigned, that he's going
to serve that anytime soon, because they have
already made clear they plan to appeal and will
ask for a stay of that sentence. Six months to
high to low. Let me know in the YouTube comments
on Twitter email in info at David Pakman dot com.